I'm in New Orleans Louisiana in the
French Quarter in the Crescent City are
the home of jazz and a really good place
to talk about zip codes no seriously
because New Orleans is on the
Mississippi which is the dividing line
between the west and the east of America
and zip codes work like this up in the
Northeast you have the zeros up in the
southwest
you have the Niners and New Orleans here
in the middle you have the seventh not
the fives that's because the population
density in the Northeast is much higher
and so neons
ran out by that rather than just
geographical location which does make
sense and there is one zip code of
course that is more famous than all
others Beverly Hills 90210 and the
reason is for committee decision some
point in the US Postal Service when they
were setting up zip codes at some point
they decided Beverly Hills will get this
arbitrary number and of course a TV show
made it famous something interesting
though they might not know but in 2000
there was a company called all advantage
and their shtick was this download a
program that would just put adverts
permanently in the bottom of your screen
like watching a YouTube video on with
everything and that advert would stay
there permanently blocking up a little
bitty screen in exchange they would pay
you quite a bit of money because this
was mm this was a dot-com boom this is
when you could get away with paying a
lot of money for banner ads and then
they added a multi-level marketing
scheme like all the dodgy pyramid
schemes that you still see today if you
referred other people you will get a
small cut of what they got and all the
people they referred would send some
money to you as well obviously the
company died their death when the
dot-com bubble crash that really didn't
need me mentioned but back in 2000 oh
this was a wonderful scheme all
advantage com released a press release
are very happy press release announcing
that the most popular zip code for their
users Beverly Hills 90210 and this was
this was astonishing because why would
the rich people of Beverly Hills want a
few dollars now putting a banner ad on
the screen if you have a referral scheme
like that where they're just giving out
free money for something you do on a
computer well people are going to cheat
it they're going to install it many
times on many computers try and get as
much money out as possible to do that
they need to fake accounts these folks
aren't in the u.s. so what they do is
they sign up with the only zip code they
know I know
so that press release that press release
in the heady days of the dot-com boom is
a result of several decisions one the US
Postal Service picking that zip code for
that area to a TV show picking that zip
code for its title and three one very
silly web service burning through a lot
of money very quickly and being scammed
for all they could take and that is
something you might not have